all of us really yeah you know I thought
you liked that thing I didn't like that
thing that's good
how close was this to being to to being
released it was not close to being
released it was about two weeks before
our due date to turn it in for mastering
and all that other stuff and and and
Pete wasn't it because is yeah I don't
know it feels like maybe it's a little
rushed and like that's because it's very
rushed right now so so when that was the
week we pulled the breakpoint all four
of us really worked speaking up and
we're kind of just going with the flow a
little bit too much I knew that was a
problem because at any given point any
record we've ever made they've always
gotten significantly better after we
started like arguing we didn't argue at
all on this when I was like that's a bad
sign that's a really bad sign I think
that we can all a boy can really make a
record that sounds like anything in 2017
except for something that we think is
like kind of mediocre
[Music]
wasn't like the record label pushed our
record back or like someone else it was
like we were like we should probably and
since then I think that the trajectory
of the songs has just been a lot better
it was kind of crazy actually how
quickly if as soon as we knew that we
were pushing it's kind of unfortunate
because the way the way release dates
work is then it's like this Lane that
you got to wait for the record got so
much better in the span of like a week
or two after after we did that because
then we knew we had the time and we
really actually buckled down and focused
on it some of the same songs that were
even recorded and known okay that's
that's true that's true but I mean but
some of the same beginnings of songs we
retooled and figured out what was good
about them and are so much better now
do you have songs in the catalogue that
you still play live that are just not
you anymore in in some ways yeah I mean
it's weirder for me because because I
have the the benefit of the separation
from the lyrics you know I sing him but
I didn't write them I was always kind of
adopting Pete's character when I was
singing them anyway so I'm so I'm still
getting in the head of you know of like
20 year old Pete and going this is crazy
wild you know
[Music]
how did the partnership with a Jaden
Smith happen I think he's just one of
those guys who is super talented and
creative and I was just like I'm just a
big fan he ended up doing a small part
in our champion music video which is
amazing too because he were just like oh
this guy did it in one take this is just
like he just did it all with his face or
something and it's like that okay so
that's what it's actually like you know
whatever like our director was like yeah
he was just like he was like I don't
really have any notes to give and then I
was like we're doing this for a couple
shows and he was like I'll play the
whole tour you know people always ask
you how you play the same songs every
night you play the song same songs every
night by watching a younger artist who's
never played to enough to this audience
before and going wow like I have to
connect to that I have to find a way to
feel like that tonight
[Music]